if you come on my leather seats you're
walking home
just asking you to suspend the dividend
and kill the stock what do you think's
gonna happen when i dump our 18 percent
share tomorrow morning
i'll tell you what the stock will drop
below 10
sec will suspend trading and every
creditor you have will file on you
your company will be chapter 11 by
friday
and since we're your largest creditors i
can promise you there'll be no
negotiating then
i will be ceo of il energy by monday
i will fire every [ __ ] employee then
i will sell your leases
and equipment to chevron for 30 cents on
the dollar
and you buddy you will have the unique
distinction
of being the only drilling company to go
bankrupt in the largest oil boom of the
last
century well that looked good on a
resume
i started this company in my garage
that's where it's gonna end up if you
don't suspend the dividend and allow us
to assume management
don't look at him you're dealing with me
now
there's a music festival and there's
stint this weekend
you want to go with me
you ruin it every time
that's funny i always remember your dick
is being bigger
i guess that's just the nostalgic
the [ __ ]
[ __ ] you should try zumba get that
cardio up
what's the [ __ ] is wrong with you
cheating death like you said everything
i do is for him and everything you do
is for you the only reason i'm here is
cause he can't trust you
you are so toxic i can barely remember
what you were like before you killed her
how's that taste you [ __ ] all right huh
all right stop
all right drive your polluted soul back
to the city where it belongs come on big
man huh
just like old times i want to see you be
a man jamie
huh be a man be a man
be a [ __ ] man
how's that for man
the man would have walked away let me
show you one more
this one isn't on the market but i know
the property well and i think we can so
why are you showing it to me
you set every large property in the
county right or sale
it's called the pelican ranch why is it
called the pelican red maybe they saw a
goose and thought it was a pelican
the [ __ ] knows it's 100 acres
what's with the wit doing some fast math
on your commission make you a little
cocky feeling good
showing us properties that aren't for
sale boy you're on a tear
i might even go home and lay some pipe
to the old lady
look at you with your cat teeth in your
spray tan get out of my office
i don't get the [ __ ] out of my office
go write up the offer when it's done
email it so i don't have to look at you
again
and when you get your commission i want
you to shove it up your waxed ass you
cheesy [ __ ] [ __ ] i hate real
estate agents you know it's allowed for
your process jamie
only yesterday you were dreaming of a
penis yeah the only thing on my mind is
how i got to clean that trough
every now and then you see something
that makes me think you're smart
and then i look at you from that shock
fades
all right i know what this is it's a cry
for help but nobody cares to offer any
beth nobody look me in the eye and tell
me what today is
it's thursday you are so
wrong no i'm not i'm the only sober
person in this conversation the only one
with the calendar on his watch so yeah
it's [ __ ] thursday the dale mother
died
that he remembers
pardon me ma'am ma'am
miss miss
should really only be applied to a woman
younger or just reaching
marrying age which in the era this
[ __ ] became common vernacular was
around 13
and since i am clearly beyond that
milestone and i'm
clearly not married the proper term for
me
would be maiden but if you call me
maiden alfred
i'm gonna stab you in the eye with this
[ __ ] fork
we have a no smoking policy really
oh looks to me like the whole place is
smoking alfred
unless the policy is just against me
smoking
which i find hard to believe because
i've never been here before
what do you want to make a scene you
ready to watch that happen
i'll get mr jenkins for you i'd
appreciate it
uh beth we're closed at the moment we're
sure oh
my sister-in-law
i'm no lawyer but i believe it's the
fourth amendment that deals with
unlawful search and seizure the search
is voluntary
sure doesn't look voluntary to me
leave her alone
get dressed
i went to high school with you
and you you babysat her husband
on her driver's license her last name
was long i doubt that's gonna save you
buddy
thank you wait
don't go
y'all miss all the fun
well i'm here
i might as well shop
oh that's nice
yeah not for me
and you
you [ __ ] i remember when you gave out
hand jobs for lunch money veronica
it was before the boot job
[Music]
and the dermabrasion the doctor dumb
enough to marry you
you know casey isn't like you
his center he doesn't set not mean
he has the potential to be just like my
father
and you owe it to casey and your son to
do everything
in your power to prevent that from
happening
my mother was the uh
my mother was the spine of this family
she was the center and without her he's
i'm the best of him die with her
and the same thing will happen to casey
when you leave him again and you will
leave him again
you're too good for this place
you're too good for this family
but next time you leave
you take casey with you
okay because he's too good for it as
well
what did you do
he kicked me out of the house and he
abandoned my campaign
i was angry and i was in a corner
what corner
a reported journalist she pretended to
be
and then she was on my campaign staff
what the [ __ ] do you do jamie
i'll give an interview about what
no what who
you're a selfish piece of [ __ ]
no wait wait yes
wait i said fight i said wait
i think i can take it from here beth
i remember the stories of having an l in
church
lies a lot of it
i think heaven's right here sells hell
one person can be walking the clouds
right next to someone enduring eternal
damnation
and god is the land
don't say it
it doesn't mean anything on a roof
under stars like a bunch of [ __ ]
hippies
hey tell me
tell me when it saves me
okay i won't say it
you